muy buenas noches estamos de regreso
para conocer las principales noticias en
materia económica de américa latina y
del resto del mundo y nos acompaña por
supuesto jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas
noches bueno vamos a comenzar en europa
porque hay preocupación no por lo que
son las consecuencias económicas del
rebrote de la pandemia de kobe 19 así es
mientras las autoridades de salud
advirtieron que la situación de salud
pública podría empeorar los encargados
de la economía ponen en duda la
previsión de crecimiento en palabras del
comisario de economía de la unión
europea paolo gento link y el panorama
optimista termino frente al aumento de
las infecciones y nuevas restricciones
en varios estados miembros la previsión
de crecimiento allí santiago era del 5%
para finales de este año y también las
economías contaban con que los europeos
libres de las restricciones saldrían a
gastar en la temporada navideña dando un
impulso a la economía de ese continente
pero el centro europeo para la
prevención y control de enfermedades
dijo que espera que la carga infecciosa
de la variante delta sea muy elevada en
diciembre y enero a menos que los
gobiernos tomen medidas drásticas y que
las vacunas aumenten veamos
cuando consecuentes
de las consecuencias al menos nuestra
estimación es que las consecuencias
económicas no serán tan graves como las
del invierno pasado been last winter
políticos
no sólo por el hecho de que la economía
está ahora más adaptada a las
infecciones sino porque tenemos vacunas
y las vacunas especialmente en los
países donde es tan fuerte y evitaran
también un impacto económico más grave
will avoid out jay mohr serios economic
impact bueno jorge contanos cómo avanza
la crisis económica en turquía que
preocupa muchísimo en el país así que
bueno la moneda oficial que es la lira
turca se recupera un 7% tras la caída
histórica que provocaron las acciones
del presidente de esa nación tayip
erdogán erdogán propuso recortar las
tasas de interés porque según él son los
que provocan el aumento de precios su
decisión contraria es contraria al resto
de los bancos centrales del mundo que
aumentan los tipos de interés para
contrarrestar la inflación la moneda
pese al repunte de hoy continúa siendo
un 38% más débil a finales del año
pasado los banqueros dijeron que la
liquidez prácticamente se había agotado
y que la caída histórica de ayer se
debía a la compra de dólares por pánico
incluso muchas personas compraron
artículos electrónicos como teléfonos
celulares con la esperanza de venderlos
un año después a un mejor precio la
oposición acusa a erdogán de llevar al
país hacia el desastre cientos de turcos
hacían filas en las gasolineras ante el
temor del aumento de precios mientras
otros participaban en protestas
dispersas contra la gestión económica
del gobierno escuchamos un poco cuál es
el sentir ahí
[Música]
esto es la ridiculez de turquía necesito
comprar gasolina necesito salir a la
carretera pero mira a esta situación
este es el estado al que han llevado a
la gente esto es una ridiculez absoluta
nada más la gente se aglutina sobre los
demás todas las gasolineras están llenas
y a tope aquí está la cola de la
gasolina que más puedo decir
américa latina' vamos a méjico jorge por
primera vez en la historia del país una
mujer va a gobernar el banco central
mexicano así que se trata de la actual
subsecretaria de egresos de la
secretaría de hacienda victoria
rodríguez ceja así lo anunció el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
durante su acostumbrada rueda de prensa
matinales y seda tras la polémica de
ayer cuando difundió que había retirado
la candidatura de arturo herrera ex
secretario de hacienda que estaba
nominado desde junio el mandatario
argumentó que el cambio de nombramiento
responde a la paridad de género que
busca su gobierno rodríguez es
licenciada en economía por el instituto
tecnológico de estudios superiores de
monterrey y cuenta con una maestría en
economía por el colegio de mexico ha
sido directora de deuda de la secretaria
de finanzas dentro del gobierno de
ciudad de méxico entre los retos a cargo
del banco central de méjico está por
ahora controlar la inflación que se
ubica arriba el 7% es la más alta en 20
años luego de la noticia el peso
mexicano se depreció y la bolsa ha
perdido terreno bueno vamos a conocer
ahora qué dicen los indicadores de la
jornada arrancamos con wall street que
cerró mixto con un relieve retroceso en
el down jones tras una jornada irregular
previa al festivo de acción de gracias'
las acciones europeas terminaron una
racha de cuatro días de pérdidas con las
acciones de telecom de italia liderando
las ganancias en américa latina' como te
comentaba la bolsa mexicana cerró a la
baja tras la anuncio del cambio titular
del banco de mexico gracias cogió por
este completísimo repaso por las
principales noticias económicas a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france 24 punto com
[Música]